[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola qué tal
yo soy rodolfo bello me encanta que me
digan bello ya tengo el apellido hay que
aprovecharlo
son rodolfo bello nachón en las mañanas
cuando no estoy arreglando digo pues
este bombón bello si es
pero cuando me volteo ya no estoy seguro
si soy macho no no
pues muy bien
yo quiero platicarles un poco que ha
pasado en mi vida y como llegué a este
tema del campus de los sueños yo siempre
he creído que las universidades son un
gran parque de diversiones los centros
de estudios los centros de educativos
son un gran parque de diversiones cuando
trabaje en una universidad muy grande
hice lo imposible para que esa
universidad fuera un gran campus de los
sueños
yo crecí en una familia llena de
profesores mi papá y mi mamá eran
maestros mis tíos eran maestros yo iba a
la escuela y en la tarde tenía en casa a
dos maestros de vacaciones íbamos a casa
de mis abuelos con mis tíos y todos eran
maestros parecía que no tenía vacaciones
parece que siempre estaba en una escuela
yo quería ser todo menos maestro porque
mis tíos se la pasaban hablando de los
problemas que hay entre los profesores
el sindicato las listas etcétera es
tendencia yo ojalá nunca sea maestro
pero mírenme me tocó ser maestro y es lo
más hermoso que me ha pasado en la vida
mi papá y mi mamá fueron mis primeros
maestros mi papá fue 40 años profesor
hoy me sigue enseñando desde el cielo
cuando nací mi papá abrió una cuenta de
banco y dijo yo quiero que mi hijo
estudio en una buena escuela y cuando
tenía 18 años junto suficiente dinero y
me dijo mi hijo vaya a esa escuela
porque quiero que usted estudie una
buena carrera llegue a la universidad y
en los últimos semestres mi servicio
social fue pues a hablar un poco sobre
talleres de emprendimiento y de
liderazgo era algo relativamente
sencillo y empecé a dar clases pues no
me costaba trabajo me iba bien pero un
día me invitaron a una universidad en la
ciudad de mexico a dar una conferencia
me preparé muy bien así exactamente como
hoy le pedí a un traje prestado mi papá
y llevaba unas cosas que se llaman
acetatos usábamos un aparato que se
llamaba proyector de acetatos que era un
foco iluminaba el acetato y proyectaba
después en una pantalla
pero yo me di cuenta que cuando llevaron
al auditorio todos eran acarreados eran
muchachos de preparatoria que no querían
estar ahí que los llevaron para llenar
el lugar empezaron a chiflar empezaron a
apostarse muy mal y ese día tuve una
gran lección le quitaban la parte de
adentro de las plumas y me alentaban sus
papelitos y se empezaban a reír se me
cayeron los acetatos se revolvieron se
me empezaba a caer el pantalón porque
era un traje prestado de mi papá yo dije
que hago aquí tienes un acordé así como
me vino como un flechazo de un profesor
de teatro porque yo estaba tomando
clases extras de teatro que dijo cuando
una parte de la audiencia
este molesta contigo te esté agrediendo
a ella entregarle más amor
me acordé de eso y empecé a hacer eso le
empecé a hablar a esa parte de la
audiencia y me acuerdo que les dije
méxico solamente puede salir adelante de
dos maneras la manera milagrosa o la
manera normal la manera normal es que
baje la virgen de guadalupe y nos
resuelva todos los problemas la manera
milagrosa es que nos pongamos a trabajar
y todos empezaron a aplaudir todos
en ese momento dije caray eso esta
interesante ese día aprendió una gran
lección decidí entonces dar clases y
empecé a dar clases de repente cuando
tenía 26 años me invitaron a irme a
monterrey y llegué a la gran ciudad de
monterrey en un campus gigantesco enorme
yo tenía 26 años de edad y tenía que
trabajar con los líderes estudiantiles
de esa gran universidad que tenían
apenas 20 18 yo tenía que ser líder de
esas personas no era sencillo era gente
muy madura era gente de todo el país
haciendo cosas realmente importantes
inclusive de otros países yo les he
dicho que siempre he querido que una
universidad es como un parque de
diversiones y entonces me dediqué a
escucharlos de manera empírica entraban
a mi oficina me contaban sus sueños y yo
trataba de hacerlos más grandes
ingeniero queremos hacer una conferencia
que vengan 50-60 personas y por qué no
300 y por qué no mil ingenieros queremos
traer a un jugador de fútbol y por qué
no yo montana' y por qué no
bill gates y por qué no steve jobs y
entonces los jóvenes empezaron a soñar y
empezaron a hacer cosas impresionantes
mi vida en monterrey cambió me casé
tuvimos a nuestros hijos allá en
monterrey mi vida en monterrey fue
impresionante porque empecé a
interactuar con muchos jóvenes estuve
con jóvenes de todos lados del mundo de
todos lados de este país y estuve
platicando y conversando acerca de sus
sueños empecé a hacer muchos eventos con
los muchachos muchos muchos eventos me
acuerdo muy bien por ejemplo una vez una
chica se lanzó como candidata a reina le
puso mucho empeño a su trabajo ella
quería ser la reina del campus hizo una
gran campaña se esforzó y perdió no le
fue bien
se sintió muy deprimida se sintió mal
sus papás me hablaron era de aquí de
tamaulipas de reynosa sus papeles no
hablaron por teléfono y me dijeron
ingeniero nuestra hija está muy
deprimida ya no quiere ir a la escuela
ya van tres días que no va necesitamos
ayuda nos enteramos que hay un evento en
san francisco en donde están invitando a
jóvenes líderes necesitan una carta y
que de alguna manera usted la promueva
para que vaya y a lo mejor cambia un
poco de vos de sensaciones y emociones y
ya no esté tan deprimida hicimos la
carta y jessica fue a san francisco al
state of the world forum quizás ustedes
conocen el world economic forum que es
en enero en davos mijail gorbachov
premio nobel de la paz hizo la
contraparte en san francisco el state of
the word forum y hace 22 años jessica
fue estuvo con madeline are break con
jesse jackson con ted turner en unas
conferencias muy inspiradoras al final
del evento le preguntaban a todos los
jóvenes que iban de todos lados del
mundo que te gustaría ser ahora que
regreses a tu país
el africano dijo voy a sembrar más
árboles el europeo voy a recoger basura
el sudamericano voy a ser un mejor
ciudadano bravo bravo y cuando le
preguntaron a jessica tú qué vas a hacer
y así que dijo voy a hacer un evento
igual en monterrey
o sea algo que puedas hacer la magia
había comenzado
jessica que había estado en monterrey se
daba cuenta que podía hacer eventos así
miren
jessica es un evento en donde llegaron
900 jóvenes de 54 países del mundo tuvo
más de 70 conferencistas cuatro premios
nobel de la paz junto un millón y medio
de dólares para hacer un gran evento esa
foto que está ahí ya sí que está al lado
derecho del ecb al esa presidente de
polonia la primera vez que vino a
américa vino porque jessica lo invitó en
esa foto que está ahí todos esos jóvenes
que están en a y ahora son exitosos uno
de ellos está trabajando en el word
economic forum otro rector de una
universidad los sueños se hacen realidad
si empiezas a hacer las cosas con
determinación a mí me gustaba que
llegaran a mi oficina
participe de sus ideas y yo lo
revolucionaria empezamos a hacer muchas
cosas muchos eventos yo empecé a
comparar a la universidad con un gran
parque de diversiones porque porque no
la universidad no cualquiera puede
llegar a veces se requiere de mucho
dinero a veces se requiere de mucho
esfuerzo pero una vez que estás adentro
del parque de diversiones tú decides qué
hacer
tú puedes llegar a una universidad y
pasarte todo el día en la cafetería
inclusive varias veces en la misma
materia tú decides si esa universidad es
la mejor universidad para ti a mí me
preguntan muchos los jóvenes ingeniero
cuál es la mejor universidad de méxico
aquella que ha conquistas
aquella que tú haces que sea la mejor
universidad la mejor universidad no es
la que tiene un título o un sello es la
que hace que tú cambies y tus sueños nos
hagan realidad para mí una universidad
es un lugar en donde puedes inspirarte
puedes encender tu corazón y puedes
empezar a hacer cosas en un viaje de una
universidad de cuatro años tu vida va a
cambiar
vas a ser diferente
pero también estar en una universidad es
como estar en una burbuja
es un lugar maravilloso mientras estás
estudiando pero una vez que sales el
país es diferente y hay que cambiarlo la
vida va a ser un antes y un después de
estar en la universidad
algo que yo aprendí con los jóvenes algo
que me di cuenta al estar de alguna
manera conversando con ellos es que
empezaban a cambiar mira yo me sé
bastantes historias de gente que ha
hecho cosas maravillosas te platiqué por
ejemplo de jessica pero un día hace 20
años llegaron unos muchachos en una
oficina y me dijeron queremos ir a china
no existía celulares no existía google
no había weiss no había manera de saber
cuánto costaba un boleto ya estando en
china para recorrer china y sin embargo
estos muchachos con faxes y todo también
juntaron recursos de las empresas y
viajaron a china esa organización se
llamó programa de liderazgo empresarial
el play este grupo de estudiantes tienen
25 años viajando por todo el mundo y
cada verano juntan un millón de dólares
de varias empresas llevan productos a
china a asia singapur a malasia y
regresan yo viajé con ellos en el 2002
imagínate este viaje
viaje todo pagado por los muchachos a la
india estuvimos en la india en bombay y
en nueva delhi de ahí nos fuimos a
singapur a burneo burneo es una isla que
está pegada a malasia conocimos singapur
conocimos tailandia luego nos fuimos
australia-nueva zelanda y ya de regreso
un descansito en hawai
imagínate nada más jóvenes de 20 años
conquistando el mundo hace 20 años
porque un muchacho podía hacer eso
porque se quería capaz creía que lo
podía hacer que aprendes en esos viajes
todo a mí me tocó ser director de becas
de esta gran universidad y los muchachos
cuando estaban ahí llegaban y me pedían
cosas una vez llegó paco y paco
necesitaba un aumento de beca necesitaba
más dinero para poder estar estudiando y
yo le empecé a preguntar a paco muy bien
para qué
opción número 1
que la universidad de más becas opción
número 2
y me decía para con o sin la universidad
no me da más dinero
pues entonces voy con el rector es lo
mismo para que estas yendo a la
universidad es que ustedes no entienden
que si no me dan más dinero mi vida va a
estar atrofiada luego haber paco es un
problema tuyo no de la universidad
tienes una beca del 80 por ciento tienes
90 de promedio en una de las carreras
más importantes de esta universidad
opción número uno que la universidad
tiene más beca opción número dos y no me
decía nada para acá
y yo te voy a ver la opción número 2
pero yo quiero que me des la opción
número 3 opción 2
porque no llevas menos materias pagas
menos y en lugar de que te tardes un año
te vas a tardar dos pero te vas a
graduar
no pero es que es una opción resuelves
tu vida en lugar de graduarte de 23
temas sagrados de 24 que importa yo
quería que paco me dijera con su 90 de
promedio que podría ponerse a trabajar
pero no me lo decía
cuando por fin le dije puedes trabajar
para pagarte ese poquito que te falta le
dije para que si tuvieras todo el dinero
del mundo en donde te encantaría
trabajar donde pagarías por trabajar y
me dijo yo pagaría por trabajar en la
nasa monterrey y houston no está tan
lejos en un autobús puedes hacer 68
horas de monterrey a houston entonces
hice un trato con para que yo voy a
hablar con el comité de becas para que
te aumente en la beca pero tú me vas a
organizar un viaje a la nasa vas a
organizar a tus compañeros y vas a
viajar a la nasa es algo que tienes que
hacer tu barco era muy tímido no le
gustaba hacer eso pero organizó ese
viaje organizó un segundo viaje un
tercer viaje y cuando organizó el cuarto
viaje que ya eran casi 200 personas en
houston en la nasa le dijeron oye tú
quién eres de dónde vienes no yo estoy
estudiando en esta universidad y tengo
este promedio y soy becado y en la nasa
le dijeron no te gustaría venirte a
trabajar para acá y cumplir su sueño
he ido aprendiendo muchas cosas al al
contacto con los jóvenes al estar
platicando con ellos he tomado mucha
información de gente que yo admiro como
walt disney como robert pulgón pero hay
alguien en particular a que yo admiro
mucho que son los huicholes este año
pasado de 9.500 profesores que ha tenido
esa universidad los estudiantes se
encontraron a los 300 que más los han
inspirado y me tocó estar elegido entre
ellos pero yo creo que ellos me han
enseñado más a mí de lo que yo pude de
lo que yo pude haberles enseñado a ellos
quiero contarte algo que me parece
formidable que es una historia de los
huicholes los huicholes es una etnia que
está en michoacán en jalisco y nayarit
son unas son unos indígenas que le
cuentan esto a sus hijos cuando tienen
16 años cuenta la historia que hace
mucho tiempo una semilla de manzana cayó
en tierra fértil imagínense que una
semilla de manzana cae en tierra fértil
y la semilla de manzana tenía un sueño
la semilla de manzana quería ver las
estrellas pero no sabía cómo entonces la
semilla de manzana le pregunto un
insecto cómo le hago para ver las
estrellas y el insecto le dijo por tu
tamaño por tu forma tu color o eres
semilla de manzana o de pera no eres
semilla de melón
ni de limón ni de aguacate eres de
manzana o de pera entonces echarle
muchas ganas y en una semana vas a
germinar la semilla de manzana les beso
echar ganas y a la semana
termino pero oh sorpresa hay muchos
arbustos hay muchos obstáculos tú te
puedes esforzar un semestre 12 meses 33
semestre puedes graduarse de la
universidad y no necesariamente hay
trabajo son obstáculos te están retando
las semillas de manzanas enojo a ese
insecto no engaño seguramente es
político porque asocian por engañan no
no no pérate no te enojes o más bien
enojarte porque no haces tener energía
pero por la energía en seguir esforzando
te
paso un mamífero le pregunto la semilla
de manzana mamífero cómo le hago para
ver las estrellas y le dijo sigue
echando ganas y la semilla de manzana le
sigue echando ganas y c's se convirtió
en un árbol grande muy bonito robusto
con un tronco grande si ven el tronco
grande verdad
con manzanas muy bonitas 7 lo que te voy
a decir porque lo dicen los huicholes
una semilla de manzana no puede dar
manzanas si no se convierte en árbol y
madura si no toma la savia de la tierra
la hace parte de si la hace integral así
sus valores y hace fotosíntesis con el
sol para refugiar en lo mejor que tiene
el árbol de manzana que son las manzanas
y entonces tomó la manzana me voy a
dirigir hacia acá
y la partió tomó la manzana y le dijo
esto que está aquí es el fruto de todo
tu trabajo tú te has esforzado todos
estos años
para ver las estrellas allá arriba y a
veces cuando vamos a estudiar una
universidad queremos al graduarnos tener
fama poder riqueza no señor lo que
tienes que hacer es cumplir tus sueños y
una vez que cumples tus sueños' darle
frutos a los demás porque vas a ver que
ahí adentro hay una estrella perfecta de
cinco picos no me digas lo que sabes
dime lo que eres capaz de hacer con lo
que sabes porque hacer algo con lo que
sabes es darle frutos a los demás es
hacer que tu árbol en ese campus de los
sueños florezca y empiece a dar muchos
frutos con muchas estrellas para los
demás
yo soy rodolfo bello me encanta que me
digan bello soy un facilitador de sueños
y le agradezco a playa miramar que me
hayan invitado muchas gracias por su
atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]